merci d'être avec nous Daniel salmon il
nous accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes élu
d'Ille-et-Vilaine donc du groupe
écologiste solidarité et territoire ici
au Sénat on va bien sûr parler du projet
de loi nucléaire puisque les sénateurs
en début de l'examen cet après-midi mais
d'abord la réforme des retraites est-ce
que vous irez manifestez-vous que je dis
bien entendu je ne sais pas encore si ce
sera si ce sera sur Rennes ou sur Paris
mais bien entendu j'y serai me semble
élémentaire vous pensez pouvoir faire
reculer le gouvernement et bien écoutez
il y a que lui qui ne sont pas menées
qui sont perdus d'avance donc il faut y
aller je pense que les Français dans
leur grande majorité sont hostiles à
cette réforme
68%. donc j'espère qu'il y aura beaucoup
de monde dans la rue et on a la
possibilité effectivement devant
l'unanimité des syndicats pour rejeter
ce projet de faire
briller le gouvernement la bataille vous
l'amènerait évidemment aussi au
Parlement comment vous comptez vos
opposer à ce texte surtout ici au Sénat
ou La droite majoritaire est favorable à
la réforme
et bien nous mènerons notre combat notre
débat démocratique nous le ferons en
nous basant sur ce qu'il reste
d'humanité dans ce pays on sait
aujourd'hui que les différences sa
croissent entre les 5% les plus riches
et les 5% les plus pauvres avec ce
départ en retraite à 64 ans on va
revenir aux années 60 ou la retraite
était l'antichambre de la mort je pense
que les Français après une année de une
année une vie de dur labeur ont droit à
un moment un peu de bonheur une
parenthèse dans leur vie et ça me semble
élémentaire aujourd'hui il faut savoir
qu'à 64 ans on part à la retraite
après l'âge où on estime que les
Français vont avoir des sous gros soucis
de santé
l'espérance de vie augmente mais
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé stagne
voire régresse et aujourd'hui on sait
que ceux qui sont les plus impactés par
cette par cette retraite c'est très
forme de la retraite ce sont les
catégories les plus défavorisées qui
vont devoir travailler encore plus
longtemps après des métiers très
pénibles c'est parce que du gouvernement
évidemment il y a des mesures pour les
carrières longues les gens qui ont
commencé à travailler avant 20 ans en ne
partiront pas à la retraite à 64 ans
mais entre 58 et 62 ans selon l'âge au
départ duquel ils ont commencé à
travailler il y a aussi des mesures pour
la pénibilité il y a aussi la prise en
compte du congé parental il y a des
retraites qui sont réhaussées pour les
gens qui ont une carrière complète et
qui ont des petites retraites il y a
rien à apprendre pour vous dans ce texte
non puisque en 2017 il y avait 10
critères de pénibilité monsieur Macron
les a fait passer à 6 vous voyez bien
monsieur le maire dit qu'on va gagner 17
milliards les 17 va bien falloir les
prendre quelque part on nous fait croire
que et ben non ça va augmenter pour
beaucoup de personnes non très peu de
personnes vont bénéficier d'une
augmentation de la retraite d'une
manière générale ce sera une baisse une
baisse
construite et qui va toucher ce que je
disais en premier les plus précaires
la tronçonne des verres de votre partie
marine tondeuillier dit vouloir
transformer l'Assemblée nationale en
Zada est-ce que pour vous ce sont des
propos responsables écoutez jade ça veut
dire zone à défendre effectivement on
est là pour défendre les retraites tout
simplement il faut le prendre dans ce
sens là et je pense que les les
républicains ou le majorité
présidentielle qui sait
[Musique]
occupé de plomber par exemple la
proposition de loi sur la corrida avec
une multitude d'amendements n'a rien n'a
pas de leçon à nous donner on va parler
de ce qui se passe aujourd'hui au Sénat
le Sénat qui entame donc l'examen du
projet de loi nucléaire qui vise à
accélérer et à construire de nouveaux
réacteurs de nouvelles centrales on va
voir ce que contient ce texte avec Alex
pousseur
[Musique]
bonjour Yann bonjour Daniel salmon
bonjour
les conditions pour tenir les promesses
d'Emmanuel Macron pendant la campagne
présidentielle sur le nucléaire à savoir
construire six nouveaux réacteurs EPR 2
et étudier la possibilité pour en
construire 8 autres supplémentaires soit
14 nouveaux réacteurs nucléaires et donc
ce projet de loi est vise à accélérer
les procédures administratives qui
pourraient ralentir ces constructions
d'abord plus besoin de permis de
construire pour ces nouveaux projets il
sera possible également d'en construire
en bord de mer malgré la loi littorale
seulement si le nouveau réacteur est
dans le périmètre d'une centrale
nucléaire existante et puis des mesures
d'expropriation immédiates sont
également prévues par ce projet loi
alors c'est un projet de loi assez
technique assez administratif et il
arrive six mois avant un texte plus
politique sur l'énergie la programmation
plus réelle de l'énergie la fameuse PPE
c'est le texte qui doit
notre mix énergétique en France et
notamment la place du nucléaire dans
notre production énergétique et pour
beaucoup de sénateurs et bien ce débat
politique doit avoir lieu avant un débat
technique sur l'accélération de la
construction de réacteurs on va écouter
un échange entre le sénateur communiste
Fabien gay et la ministre en charge de
la transition énergétique Agnès
pourquoi ce projet de loi maintenant
madame la ministre parce que pour le
coup vous avez raison le nucléaire c'est
du temps long 15 20 25 ans de
construction 40 60 ans d'exploitation
vous avez dit qu'il y a tout un tas de
questions qui seront dans la PPE et vous
commencez à y répondre parce que vous
êtes obligé de faire de la politique
parce que c'est un texte extrêmement
technique mais en même temps on veut
faire de la politique
la ce texte il est important pour parce
que en fait on a analysé la conduite du
projet de nouvelles centrales nucléaires
en faisant un rétroplanning et donc le
dossier administratif et les dossiers de
permis de construire doivent être
adaptés dès maintenant si on veut
effectivement livrer des réacteurs
nucléaires dans 15 ans là aussi c'est
ce sont des dossiers qui prennent
plusieurs années ce projet de loi est
permis de gagner plusieurs années et la
coulé du premier béton si on veut tenir
cet objectif de couler du premier béton
à 5 ans ça suppose que ce projet de loi
soit adopté avant la fin du premier
semestre
de communication pour Emmanuel Macron de
voir la première coulée de béton d'un
nouveau réacteur nucléaire avant la fin
du quinquennat en 2027 alors la majorité
de droite du Sénat qui est plutôt pro
nucléaire devrait être favorable à ce
projet loi mais tout en adoptant
certaines modifications des
modifications qui ont d'ailleurs déjà
été voté cette semaine par les sénateurs
en commission les sénateurs de droite
qui ont supprimé l'objectif de limiter à
50% la part du nucléaire dans notre mix
énergétique en 2035 et plus long
remplacé par un nouvel objectif de
maintenir à au moins 50% la part du
nucléaire dans notre mix énergétique en
2050 la majorité sénatoriale qui veut
donc lancer avant l'heure prévue par le
gouvernement un débat politique sur le
nucléaire Daniel salmon c'est plutôt
cohérent de la part d'Emmanuel Macron et
du gouvernement de faire ce texte pour
accélérer la construction de nouveaux
réacteurs car leur objectif c'est de
relancer la filière c'est la promesse de
campagne l'annonce c'est pas logique du
tout et là il y a un accord entre sur
différents bancs du Sénat pour dire que
vient faire ce projet de loi à cet
instant alors que l'on va débattre de
mix énergétique de la France dans 6 mois
on met la charrue avant les vœux c'est
anti-démocratique une fois de plus mais
le nucléaire ne rime pas souvent avec la
démocratie et là en fin de compte le
seul objectif de ce projet de loi c'est
d'essayer d'aller vers le fait accompli
et d'éviter le débat le débat au
Parlement mais aussi le débat au sein
des Français en ce moment il y a la
commission nationale du débat public qui
organise un débat sur la paire de
réacteurs de pinly on est en cœur au
cœur du débat et on va déjà mettre une
loi d'accélération alors qu'on ne sait
pas du tout de quel mix on veut est-ce
que l'on veut du nouveau nucléaire les
Français n'ont pas été franchement
interrogés sur le sujet et nous notre
position elle n'a pas varié nous sommes
et nous restons anti-nucléaire alors sur
la forme du coup la majorité des
sénateurs de droite ont raison de
relancer ce débat politique en parlant
d'objectif de part du nucléaire dans
notre production mais ce que sur le fond
ils ont raison de supprimer cet objectif
de limiter à 50% le nucléaire dans notre
mix énergétique en 2035 écoutez cet
amendement du rapporteur
n'a rien à faire dans ce texte là
puisque on va parler de la programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie on en parlera
au sein de la loi de programmation
énergie et climat on va parler de la
stratégie nationale bas carbone à ce
moment là
ça n'a rien à faire là mais sur le
principe
sur le principe ça n'a rien à faire dans
ce texte on entend ce que vous dites
mais sur le principe est-ce qu'ils ont
raison de dire qu'il faut maintenir au
moins 50 % la part du nucléaire en 2050
clairement non moi je vais vous donner
notre positionnement pourquoi nous
restons antinocléaire est-ce que vous
trouvez que le monde est stable
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous pensez qu'il
va gagner en stabilité si on regarde un
peu dans le rétroviseur en 2019 qui
avait vu venir le covid qui avait vu
venir la guerre en Ukraine à cette de
cette ampleur là et même le président
est surpris de voir qu'il y a un
réchauffement climatique écoutez
on a une sédimentation des crises on a
même plus d'espace de respiration et
toutes les études et ceux qui seront
surpris et bien on en reparlera toutes
les études montrent qu'on va vers des
périodes d'instabilité de plus en plus
importantes des instabilités au niveau
géopolitique on va avoir de plus en plus
de migrations et des instabilités en
lien avec le réchauffement climatique
qui va amener un nombre incalculable
d'aléa climatique donc comme on le
disait Fabien gay le nuclé c'est le
temps long c'est à dire ce qu'on va
construire ici ça sera toujours en
activité potentiellement en 2100 on ne
sait pas ce qui va se passer dans 5 ans
on ne sait pas ce qui va se passer dans
10 ans encore moins peut-être à plus 4
degrés en 2100 donc nous engager dans le
nucléaire c'est un aveuglement c'est une
épée de Damoclès qu'on met au-dessus des
la tête des générations futures
géopolitique pour sortir du nucléaire
c'est un argument mais il y a aussi
l'instabilité énergétique on le voit la
France n'est pas passé loin des coupures
de courant cet hiver alors apparemment
on s'en éloigne et ce que justement une
part plus importante des énergies
renouvelables qui sont intermittentes
dépendantes du temps qu'il fait est-ce
que ça va pas renforcer cette
instabilité énergétique du pays alors
déjà pour vous dire la stabilité cet
hiver
c'est pas les renouvelables depuis six
mois c'est le nucléaire le nucléaire qui
à cause simplement du covid qui était
une pandémie je on va pas discuter là
dessus mais qui a réussi à bloquer la
maintenance des centrales nucléaires la
corrosion sous contrainte les aléas
climatiques qui ont fait que cet été un
certain nombre de rivières n'étaient
plus en capacité de refroidir les
centrales tout ça a fait que le
nucléaire qui est soi-disant une énergie
très très stable là était plus
qu'intermite en donc la problématique
vient de là alors
d'investissement aussi parce qu'il y a
une volonté de baisser le nucléaire et
donc les gouvernements n'ont pas investi
sur le nucléaire ce n'est pas que cela
hélas
alors je veux bien qu'on nous accuse de
tous les mots mais les trois raisons que
je vous ai donné pour la problématique
du nucléaire cet été ça n'a rien à voir
avec les écologistes c'est pas nous qui
gérons la maintenance
pourquoi cela fonctionne aussi mal avec
le nucléaire et bien tout simplement
parce que c'est une énergie qui est
effectivement demande des
investissements constants on va avoir
besoin de d'un grand carénage allez 42 à
75 milliards on va avoir besoin derrière
toujours de la filière déchets avec sigo
là aussi des chiffres fantaisistes entre
42 enfin entre 27 et 40 milliards donc
EDF est déjà largementdété le nucléaire
est non seulement extrêmement dangereux
mais aujourd'hui on sait que c'est une
énergie très coûteuse mais est-ce qu'on
peut s'en passer parce que en 2035 il y
aura plus de ventes de véhicules à
moteur thermique il y aura plus que des
véhicules électriques la production la
nécessité le besoin en électricité va
augmenter dans le pays est-ce qu'on va
pouvoir y faire face en nucléaire
écoutez on n'est pas tout nu il y a
plein de scénarios il y a des scénarios
alternatifs ce ne sont pas les
écologistes qui les ont mis qui les ont
proposé
et le directeur de RTI monsieur pezazic
la dit plusieurs fois le scénario 100%
renouvelable est parfaitement crédible
on est là devant un choix de société un
choix qui va impacter la vie des
Français et la vie des Européens pendant
des décennies je pense que ça mérite un
vrai débat et qu'on s'en occupe
sérieusement ensuite la ritournelle le
nucléaire va sauver le climat c'est
vraiment une ritournelle vous voyez bien
que c'est réacteur au mieux
ils seront prêts en 2037 2040 avec je
vous le dis des calendriers complètement
fantaisistes de EDF il suffit de
regarder le PR1 on voit ce que cela peut
donner donc le nucléaire arrivera trop
tard trop cher trop tard et trop
dangereux d'un autre texte qui était
présenté un peu couplé à celui-ci
c'était un texte sur l'accélération des
énergies renouvelables justement les
députés écologistes à l'Assemblée ne
l'ont pas voté est-ce que vous le
regrettez écoutez ils ont un certain
nombre d'arguments tout à fait
encendables nous nous l'avons voté à
l'issue de la de la session
au Sénat parce que nous étions dans une
dynamique où nous avions gagné un
certain nombre d'amendements et nous
semblait que cela allait dans le bon
sens mais nous avions bien entendu
pointer un certain nombre de choses qui
devaient s'améliorer à l'Assemblée
nationale or que or certaines choses se
sont améliorées mais d'autres se sont
dégradés donc on si on fait la balance
c'est pas franchement mieux il y a des
problèmes de planification il y a des
choses qui ont été retirées en termes de
développement massif de du
photovoltaïque donc effectivement je
comprends
députés et sénateurs sur ce texte bah
écoutez je suis un peu sceptique mais
bon on peut toujours avoir une bonne
surprise et ce sera la semaine prochaine
la recherche d'un accord entre députés
et sénateurs sur ce texte merci Alex à
tout à l'heure on va parler pénurie de
médicaments ce sera à suivre évidemment
dans le club on va voir l'actualité dans
votre département on va aller à Rennes
maintenant Daniel salmon retrouver il
m'arrive au bain bonjour Yves-Marie
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
Yves-Marie de Ouest-France et on revient
avec vous et Marie sur la tempête qui a
touché hier l'ouest de la France entre
autres effectivement les tempêtes se
suivent dans l'Hexagone et pas seulement
sociales au cours de la nuit de dimanche
à lundi puis toute la journée d'hier
Gérard a soufflé sur la France
conséquence des arbres des racines
coupures d'électricité train à l'arrêt
bateau endommagé forte pluie et même
Blizzard en altitude Gérard a été
violente dans l'ouest une rafale à 163
km/h a été enregistré à
Barneville-Carteret sur le littoral
normand et une pointe à 100 km/h à
l'intérieur des terres en Mayenne plus
de 90 000 clients ont été privés
d'électricité notamment en Normandie
Bretagne et dans les Pays de la Loire et
un automobiliste et même mort près de
Bordeaux après avoir percuté un arbre
tombé sur la route place maintenant à
Fiennes cette dépression va balayer le
sud de ce mardi générant des des forts
dans l'Aquitaine de l'Aquitaine à
l'Occitanie je leur ai dit qu'il aura le
provençales et puis en Corse sans parler
des gros cumuls de pluie avec un risque
de cru associé alors Monsieur salmon
avec le dérèglement climatique est-ce
que ces tempêtes vont-elles se faire
plus fréquente
écoutez là aussi pas de surprise tous
les modèles le monde vous avez un
réchauffement global donc des océans des
mers qui se réchauffent donc plus
d'évaporation donc plus potentiellement
de tempêtes parce que effectivement
quand on a des différences de
température comme cela cela génère cela
génère des événements tempé de feu et
donc effectivement on le voit à travers
toute la planète ces événements-là vont
devenir de plus en plus fréquents et de
plus en plus violent donc très
clairement il y a un rapport avec le
réchauffement climatique
et on va continuer à parler
environnement puisque à lire aujourd'hui
dans Ouest-France Yves Marie Robin un
dossier sur ses défenseurs de
l'environnement à travers le monde qui
mettent leur viande en danger oui
effectivement c'est notre une du jour
plus de 1700 personnes ont été
assassinées ces dernières années dans le
monde pour avoir défendu le droit à leur
terre dans un environnement sain alors
que l'on dit Brésil Mexique les pays
d'Amérique latine sont principalement
concernés le niveau de correction y est
plus élevé parmi les victimes l'agronome
français Benoît Maria 52 ans il a été
assassiné le 10 août 2020 alors qu'il
roulait en camionnette près d'un village
montagneux du Guatemala la justice
guatémaltèque a été priée par le
gouvernement français de juger les
auteurs de ce meurtre mais la famille de
Benoît barrien Maria pardon attend
toujours le procès comment éviter de
telle meurtre à l'avenir et mieux
défendre les droits des défenseurs de
l'environnement l'association AVSF a
opté pour la médiatisation la
médiatisation des défenseurs de la
nature a du bon j'en sais quelque chose
nous rappelle le Gabonais Marcona et
Sanguy solidaire des paysans en danger
sous vétérans de la lutte pour
l'environnement à multiplier les séjours
en prison pour cette opposé à des
projets miniers et forestiers qui ne
profitaient qu'à la famille élargie de
marbongo le président du Pays de 1967 à
2009 monsieur Salman défendent
l'environnement on le voit et dangereux
est-ce que c'est la même chose en France
écoutez c'est dangereux partout on va le
dire nous avions avec mes collègues
sénateurs reçus l'année dernière des
chefs Yanomani effectivement ce sont des
gens qui sont exposés et qui sont
exposés et bien aux milices qui sont
exposés aux chercheurs d'or et il nous
faut vraiment médiatiser leur action
pour essayer de les protéger par cette
médias médiatisation en France
effectivement il n'est pas toujours aisé
non plus de d'avoir des positions
d'une liberté d'action pour défendre
l'environnement peut-être que Monsieur
Macron ou monsieur Darmanin est
qualifierait les chefs canomanie de écho
terroristes également je pense que
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui l'environnement est vraiment
en danger les peuples indigènes sont en
danger et chez nous et bien ce sont les
générations futures qui font preuve de
beaucoup de qui ressentent beaucoup des
cours anxiété et qui agissent parce que
lorsque l'on agit on a l'impression de
moins subir donc effectivement chez nous
effectivement il y a cette problématique
de la protection on peut on peut parler
de lanceur d'alerte également parce que
les problématiques environnementales
sont cruciales et le vende devenir de
plus en plus dans les années à venir
mais pour vous tous les moyens sont bons
puisque vous reparler de ce mode
éco-terroriste on le rappelle c'était
l'heure des manifestations contre les
bassines à sainte-souligne il y a pas eu
des affrontements entre les militants
écologistes et les forces de l'ordre
c'est à ce moment-là que Gérard Darmanin
les avait qualifiés des CA terroristes
tous les moyens sont bons pour défendre
l'environnement je dirais plutôt que
tous les mots ont un poids il faut pas
employer n'importe quel mot n'importe
quand le terrorisme est associé aux
épisodes sanglants que l'un inconnu en
France ça n'a rien avoir avec une action
contre des bassines illégales on faut
regarder de quel côté la légalité
également nous nous privilégions les
actions non-violes bien entendu mais
quelque part je comprends qu'il y a des
gens excédés lorsque la justice a fait
son œuvre et a considérer que c'était
illégal et que rien ne se passe
effectivement là on est en train de
pousser les gens dans des actions qui
sont pas celles que nous nous
préconisons merci merci beaucoup merci
on revoit la ligne de Ouest-France
comment protéger ceux qui défendent la
planète c'est à la Une de votre journal
merci Marie Robin on va parler d'un
sujet que vous suivez particulièrement
ici au Sénat Daniel salmon c'est le
dossier de la chasse puisque le
gouvernement a donc présenté la semaine
dernière son plan pour sécuriser la
pratique un plan qui s'inspire largement
des travaux du Sénat création d'un délit
d'alcoolémie mais pas de jour
d'interdiction de chasse qu'avez-vous
pensé de ces mesures
on voit bien qu'on a un gouvernement
complètement hors sol on vient on l'a vu
tout à l'heure sur les retraites 69% des
gens sont contre ces réformes 78% des
Français sont pour avoir des jours
nationaux sans chasse et bien il y a
rien du tout rien qui passe pour qui
pourquoi si on le comprend bien c'est
une histoire de lobbying une fois de
plus parce que les Français également
attendent
c'est ce signe qu'on les considère le
monde a changé le monde rural a changé
et dans ce monde rural la grande
majorité des habitants aspire à pouvoir
se promener en paix on avait la chanson
déjeuner en paix je pense que se
promener en paix me semble essentiel
alors bien entendu il y a la sécurité la
sécurité ressentie également quand vous
vous promenez le dimanche
c'est pas franchement pour entendre des
coups de des coups de feu même si c'est
à 1 km ou à 2 km on peut pas dire que la
promenade va être paisible donc il y a
un moment il y a ce droit ce droit au
silence ce droit à écouter les bruits de
la nature et pas être parasité et ça je
pense que les chasseurs
sont prêts à l'entendre pour une partie
d'entre eux aujourd'hui
sarcouter là-dessus empêcher ses jours
de nonchas est un non-sens et je suis
persuadé qu'il faudra y revenir dans les
deux ou trois ans comment vous allez
justement parce que on imagine que vous
allez continuer à mener ce combat pour
demander l'interdiction d'un jour de
chasse comment de quelle manière
la meilleure manière pour que ça change
ça serait de changer de gouvernement
mais ça va pas se faire tout de suite
parce que nous nous sommes des
démocrates donc effectivement les lois
se font là on verra ce que choisissent
les Français plus tard mais on va
continuer
ça sera peut-être ça mais hélas hélas on
est souvent rattrapé par l'effet si on
peut parler de faits divers mais on aura
sûrement de nouveaux accidents qui vont
remettre
l'expression est un peu un peu osée mais
le feu aux poudres une autre actualité
au Sénat c'est la constitution de la
commission d'enquête sur l'efficacité
des politiques publiques en matière de
rénovation énergétique c'est une demande
des sénateurs écologistes c'est un
levier important pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique est-ce que vous
demandez à travers cette commission
d'enquête plus d'argent publique écoutez
on voudrait déjà voir comment est
employé l'argent public
tout le monde le dit la rénovation
thermique en France
n'est pas du tout à la hauteur je vais
pas parler de fiasco mais on n'est pas
loin de ça puisque on devrait rénover
allez 600 000 passoires thermiques par
an
l'année dernière on en a rénové 2500 je
parle de rénovation globale qu'est-ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui avec ma prime
rénov c'est qu'on a facilité les
rénovations très partiel les rénovations
par gestes beaucoup de gens ont changé
leur mode de chauffage passer d'une
chaudière gaz à une pompe à chaleur des
petits gestes comme ça qui ne
transforment pas du tout le logement on
sait que lorsqu'on a fait un geste on va
remettre 4 5 10 ans avant de faire un
deuxième ce qu'il faut aujourd'hui c'est
une vraie politique pour que lorsqu'on y
va et bien on aille vraiment vers une
rénovation globale qui va diviser par 4
par 5 ou par 10 les factures de
chauffage et avec Laurent chérissement
effectivement d'énergie tout cela
excusez-moi et de plus en plus
urgent
un dernier mot puisque vous présidez ici
au Sénat le groupe d'amitié France Népal
et évidemment on pense à cette
catastrophe aérienne la plus meurtrière
depuis 30 ans le crash de cet avion qui
a fait près de 70 morts alors au-delà de
l'émotion est-ce que vous attendez des
réponses
écoutez je me suis déplacé au Népal en
septembre dernier et ce sujet était sur
la table les Népalais demandait à ce que
l'on ouvre nos aéroports aux avions
issus de leur pays
ça n'a pas été fait parce que il y a et
bien un certain nombre d'exigences
réglementaires de maintenance que ne
fait pas que ne font pas les compagnies
népalaises donc là on le voit aussi il y
a besoin d'une maintenance il a besoin
d'une d'une rigueur et je pense que là
ça va réinterroger le gouvernement
népalais sur ces exigences d'entretien
merci Daniel salmon merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité pendant cette
première demi-heure dans 20 minutes dans
le club des territoires on parlera
pénurie de médicaments qui touche le
pays cette situation va-t-elle durer et
où en est-on de la relocalisation de la
production promise par Emmanuel Macron
on verra ça dans 20 minutes d'abord on
accueille notre prochaine invité c'est
Brice Vallot